that's what i was the final against
barcelona and wembley
i should have changed at halftime and
poop jesus and park and messi
that was a mistake if i had played jason
park against messi
i think would have beat him i really do
hi it's gary neville here and we'll be
putting the sport bible audiences
questions to the boss
ahead of the release of his new film sir
alex ferguson never give in
you looking forward to it i'm ready
first question
who is the one player you wish you'd
managed that you never did
paul gascoigne without question i think
he was the best english player since
bobby charlton
i think it was fantastic boy
unfortunately we didn't get him
and i think working back now
he made a big mistake he recognized
himself years later
but we had jordi's in the camp with
bobby charlton
brian robson steve bruce even gary
powerson from middlesbrough
with people there that would have taken
care of him
you know particularly brian robson he
was fantastic with players as you know
so he goes to an island in london
you know and you're easily swallowed up
there for a young lad
and i think that was a big mistake by
him and he was a marvelous player
i loved his strength and his we played
the
newcastle up there and it was easter
monday i think and
he'd just come back from injury or near
the bomb of the week and as soon as they
come back they started winning games
and i went there with point three in the
middle of the pitch whiteside robson and
remy moses
you know right midfield he destroyed
them
honestly and then he not made any moses
right in front of the dog out
and patted him the head and i'm jumping
out the box
honestly it was unbelievable and i said
to my neighbors coming back to bus
sign this boy get on the boat phone to
them monday
and by that time they'd already done a
deal with tottenham
which is real unfortunate i was a
disappointment because
he already agreed to sign and then
taught him changed his mind by buying
his mother and father a house
you were known for buying the mother and
father a house well martin
luther saw that tape
is there anyone from the current games
who you wish you'd bought anyone who's
been playing the last 20 years
that you thought oh i'd love to manage
them well i
i think that i think kane
i thought dewally was going to be a top
player i must admit
i don't know what's happened there um
but keynes
definitely been and the boys sawing at
toronto these are
excellent players aguero has been a
terrific striker
there's no doubt about that his goal
scoring has been exceptional
and i think that that the top teams will
always produce
a player that can stand out and i think
that
those two in particular excluding old
trafford which ground had the best
atmosphere you've ever experienced
one in england and one in europe hamden
park
without doubt when it's 140 thousand 130
seconds i put in front under 36 000
and uh went to see the scotland england
games oh electric the atmosphere was
absolutely electric
and anfield and field electric i mean
you've been there you know what it's
like by the hill
it's it's uh it's marvelous atmosphere
to win
but yeah but your tx you know they
expect that atmosphere to be
even if you're losing you mean you never
felt safe that never
never really i mean literally i know
it was um it was a really volatile
atmosphere yeah i remember once she left
me out anfield
and he said gary i'm not putting you on
the bench i went okay i'll put me on the
bench
i've started every week i can't have you
warming up in front of that lot
[Laughter]
who's the most underrated player that
you managed the three players
i can't sweat them brian mcclaire
jason park and ronnie johnson it's
interesting because when you
i mean obviously i didn't i played with
brian at the end of his career but with
g
and with ronnie if there was a problem
in the game they would almost be like
your
they'd fix your problem for you so json
part would go and sit on payload and man
mark him
or ronnie would play midfield away in
europe in a champions league quarter
final where there was a down there or
there was a
you know they were the players that you
sort of trusted to do the job for you to
man mark if
you you did my mark a couple of times
that's what i was the final against
barcelona and wembley
i should have changed at halftime and
poop cheese and park and messi
that was a mistake i realized after 10
minutes i was going to do it half time
and they'll say well we could just
equalize before half time they may
see the game differently and we may
grow into the game better we're actually
quite good in the last 10 minutes of
that game you know we come into it and
we could have been in front actually
but um if i had played jason park
against messi
i think would have beat him what do we
do massive
two highways i mean a fantastic goal
scoring they made it
made the other one you know it was a
great player
but if it was a player we were going to
do it it was jason parker
if you had to pick one striker that
you've worked with to start every week
who would that striker be so it's a
striker to save your life
i couldn't do it honestly you have to
okay this is love bible you can't bottle
it
i'll give you a statistic and this is
the test for you
i had 17 strikers my time at united all
internationals
name them me
how have you got out a bottle of
question and turned it on me
well that's that's that's for your bed
at night time that will keep you on
the 17th we'll put it to the love bible
uh audience
you're not going to pick a striker for
me no a penalty then a penalty
got a penalty feel last minute
your last ever game who's checking out
of all them 17 strikers
vanessa roy or cantona or iron
one of them a dependent that went two
great penalties you know he did yeah
i think we missed one in scoring the
rebound uh
cantina missed one i think i don't think
difference through
i don't think finisher i don't know
he was deadly well arsenal keon jumping
up and down in front of him
keon's jumping idiot
you like martin keown cancel that
he's a nice boy
[Laughter]
he liked that line actually that's i
think he would gain some he
has a compliment martin knowing him i
which young managers currently working
in the premier league do you highly rate
young managers yeah you can go managers
if you want well
i mean i think the two to my mind the
two exceptional managers of clough and
guardiola
without doubt and i i i've watched them
working
and i've actually been
partly responsible with the next moves
you know
because i met them it's not your fault
is it no no no no
where club met me in switzerland and
asked for advice about moving to england
and this is
pick the best team pick a team with
expectation
and i didn't at that time i wasn't
retiring yeah
and the same way guardiola i met him in
new york with dinner together
and says keep me in touch with your next
movies
and he went to see you know but um these
two are exceptional managers
on young managers eddie had a great
period at
bournemouth for a young manager and i
think he did very well even though
even even though he's relegated it
doesn't mean to say he's not a good
manager i think he is a good manager
and i think the boy parker at film has
done a great job
because i've watched them a lot and they
keep playing the football
they don't change don't panic
they keep to the beliefs of the manager
and i think that's a great
indication how good he is which player
that you managed achieved more than you
thought they would
i think um like you'd win
i do you thought it was really bad then
didn't you and i thought steve bruce
was amazing that if you look at his
physical
being as he was not exactly over six
foot
but he attacked every ball they had to
and i think that yeah steve would be one
that
i thought did really well since that
first couple years of cristiano when he
was frustrating
did you always think that he would get
to the level that he did oh absolutely
well his game his first game against is
in
in sporting lisbon you took the day off
out there
and they rested rested and john o'shea
had to pull right back he was and he was
amazing the kid
he was always 17 he's come up for 18 of
course but
he was he was amazing but you know we
had
all that prepared to bring him to the
club
uh but it was going to be the next year
that was the arrangement yeah
and carlos curious organized it without
supporting lesbian people but then
he committed the first team and he's a
sensation
and immediately real madrid arsenal were
all
hovering and we had to move quickly
unfortunately
got me in a little room after the game
said to him only come back
come back in a plane with us he's doing
no money see my mother that's kidnapping
it
could be and uh the next day we got a
private plane brought him and his mother
and his sister and his brother
and his lawyer over and he said right
next question
which young player in world football do
you rate the highest
young football young footballer yeah in
the world
mason greenwood with my in my opinion
he's going to be a top player
is he's got the the coolness and
coolness
of a great striker he never panics
his shots are always low he's always
inside the post
and i think that that's shown great
qualities
he's young he's younger than the boy
ford and i think he's 21 i think
he is and he is uh
the one player that's come through city
has never taken the place of silver
and it's been tremendous yeah those two
in england are the best yeah
i'm asking for his thoughts on the lad
bible first
hopefully bikes
honestly boss these things are off the
scale think of it as
um
hi it's gary neville and the boss is
going to be taking off
taking you'll be answering
more frustrating watching me as a
presenter than it was as a player
was like
you did cause me some embarrassing
moments
[Laughter]
thank you perfect well done
[Applause]
oh goal of the year goal of the year
the person that's called the goal he had
the
argument with the goalkeeper before the
game
oh that was a great own goal you ever
done anything like that
not yet no yet i hope i won't